so why don't we talk first about sort of
how you came to do what you're doing
right now and then we'll talk about how
your political views
were formed over time because they they
do seem to to move and evolve over time
in a way that's really unique in the
space
so first i think that you know to talk
about you know
kind of how you came to prominence in
this in this space in the first place
uh my my first uh experience seeing some
of your stuff was during the occupy wall
street protest when you were the only
person who was out there actually taking
footage and covering that stuff
um but how did you get started in this
area well it started with occupy wall
street
so i had been doing non-profit work
i had you know i've been hanging out
with hackers and this was back in like
the days of anonymous and some other
hacker groups
and so the big core ideology behind what
we did and why we did it and it was
mostly other people i wasn't super
active
was making sure people had access to
information be it get them the internet
or give them the key details as to
what's going on
and then all of a sudden you had these
journalists say well that's journalism
you're sharing information you're
disseminating that stuff
so for me i ended up on the east coast
and then when i saw occupy wall street
happened i was just some you know
i just left california i'm just some guy
who's skateboarding and making videos
and i decided to go
and start filming eventually start live
streaming
and while i'm streaming i'm giving my
thoughts on what's happening and
essentially doing this raw
live commentary i had this big moment
where i did a live stream for 22 hours
straight
people were like running up to find me
to give me batteries to keep it going
and then i started just covering
conflict and crisis from there
i went from some guy who's live
streaming these protests to actually
working for vice
and being i was the founding member of
vice news the like the actual vertical
where i went on the ground to various uh
countries you know like venezuela like
turkey brazil
went to egypt watched the revolution
happen and i was just covering the
conflict and crisis stuff there
eventually the conflict in crisis came
to the u.s
so i ended up working for a company
called fusion they
they started out trying to be like vice
and this is a this was at a time as 2014
when these companies all started getting
super woke
i've never been particularly interested
in you know the weird cultural far-left
stuff
even though i saw it at occupy wall
street i was like i think that's kind of
ridiculous
so i ended up working with this company
but within seven or eight months
they got a new editor-in-chief all of a
sudden everything they're doing is woke
so they essentially put me in you know
what we call golden handcuffs
i was getting i was paid really well to
work for this you know disney company
but they didn't want to use real like
on-the-ground
conflict reporting because they wanted
to do video segments about
you know woke stuff i guess but
ultimately my contract ended
i started doing my own youtube channel
and i started by actually traveling
around so i went to sweden
i did a two-week like daily vlog from
sweden interviewing people seeing what
was going on
this was when donald trump did that
there was that famous moment where he
said last night in sweden you see what
happened
and the media went nuts that was a crazy
moment for me because all of a sudden
i had my colleagues from vice who used
to help me
go to these countries messaging me
saying don't go to sweden to cover the
story
and i was confused why wouldn't i like i
went to egypt
i went to ukraine i went to a bunch of
countries no no but don't do this one
trump's lying and i'm like i don't know
i don't know anything about this i don't
know anything about trump or what he's
talking about
i just heard there are some claims about
you know refugees and crime
i'm gonna go and investigate it those
they got really really mad at me and
that was when i could see like
this weird split starting to emerge so
from there
i come back to the u.s and i started
covering the conflicts we see on the
ground in the us you know proud boys
antifa that kind of stuff
and of course what do i see 99 percent
of the time
you get some trump supporters waving
little american flags and antifa shows
up and attacks them
i would report it antifa would get
really mad at me
so they started threatening me doxxing
me i someone posted a photo of my mom at
one point
and so that was like for me i think
i already had some you know personal
biases going back to my upbringing in
chicago
but now it's all i'm trying to do is
cover what's happening on the ground and
by telling the truth
these extremists and like antifa type
people were attacking me and threatening
me
and that i mean was kind of uh
i guess to be expected but it did set me
off on a path where for one
i couldn't actually go on the ground
anymore so i i slowly stopped doing it
because it was getting more and more
dangerous so then i started doing more
and more
news commentary and analysis to kind of
make up
for the fact that i couldn't be on the
ground you know aggregate more of the
people who actually are doing the work
and i kind of feel like it's not a
completely uncommon track for
journalists to go from
field reporter and then eventually later
in their career they find themselves as
like a news commentary kind of person
and then uh once it just became
completely obvious that
you know it happened when i went to
portland i had some guy chasing me
around
yelling like while i'm trying to film
and i'm like okay
clearly i got you know too many people
know who i am they're seeking me out
they're causing trouble they're trolling
or they're actually attacking me so i'm
gonna have to stop coming to a lot of
these events
and then just report to the best of my
abilities from the desk
i just started increasing the amount of
work i started doing i started doing
multiple segments per day now i think i
do
um an hour and 45 minutes of direct
commentary and i do a total of like
i do an additional two hours of a live
podcast show
which brings me to this position where
now i'm kind of this i think as you
mentioned like a heterodox
individual don't really fit necessarily
anywhere
uh although i think i've been classified
as like cultural right wing
whatever that means but my political
positions
are kind of just like where democrats
used to be it's a weird position to be
in
i i will say i think the easiest way to
explain that i'm
not orthodox i suppose in some capacity
like i'm
a heterodox personality is whenever they
try and smear
people who are you know like like right
now you got a lot of people on
podcasts and youtube for instance that
are saying the elections not over
you get these articles saying or cnn for
instance you've got the the right wing
media
lying claiming elections not over but
they never mention me
because if they do they show you like
you know my my segments are actually
very i don't know i don't i don't say
bland but uh
the the joke is that i'm a milk toast
fence sitter i will tell you
we have a sworn affidavit from numerous
you know poll watchers
but i'm not going to come out and scream
the election was stolen and
and and trump won i'm just going to say
we should investigate this it doesn't
really work very well for the mainstream
media to smear me as some kind of
conspiracy theorist
when i don't make an assertion beyond
here's a fact so
ultimately i find myself in this weird
position where for one if you go to
like my my flagship channel with the
most subscribers it's like basically the
media is trash and the democrats are too
so then people see that and they say tim
pool must be right wing
but then when it comes to actual policy
like my politics are probably you know
independent center left and i disagree
with conservatives on a lot of core
issues
that result in trump supporters getting
mad at me it's a weird position i don't
know but
ultimately that's where i'm at now and
then i guess at some point ben shapiro
hit me up and asked me to come on his
show so
yeah so i want to talk with you about uh
you know you obviously we're covering
antifa
you've covered in detail uh black lives
matter and you mentioned sort of
the woke phenomenon i don't talk about
the phenomenon and then i want to talk
about what i think is actually a more
important issue
which is the meta phenomenon of how how
social media and the media refuse to
cover this phenomenon
how they have decided that certain
narratives are worth cultivating
and certain narratives must be barred
certain narratives must be suppressed
because to me that is the the scarier uh
the scarier phenomenon is sort of the
mainstream deciding
what we can and cannot see there's
there's the radicals and they're scary
but they're kind of a small proportion
of the population then you actually have
like this mainstream phenomenon
of attempting to quash any discussion of
the radicalism which
effectively makes them enablers so let's
talk about antifa so you covered antifa
on the ground we've been told by the
media that antifa
are alternatively world war ii era
allied troops storming the beaches of
normandy uh we've been told by joe biden
that they are not in fact a group
that they are in fact just sort of a
philosophy you know sort of like
sort of like cubism or something like an
artistic movement what exactly is antifa
since you've covered them on the ground
it's a uh i mean it's not necessarily
wrong to say that they're a movement or
an idea but it's the individual cells
that we're talking about i think
what you're talking about and what they
do is the mainstream media uses a
semantic
argument to try and act like they don't
exist so to put it simply
antifa is the symbols they use the
ideology
typically fi you'll find many of these
people are authoritarian communists
and i'm not trying to exaggerate or do
some stupid oh they're all communists
not like
they're literally they believe in
authoritarian communism but
uh it's it's rooted in you know world
war pre-world war two germany
weimar germany where you had the
communist party had their anti-fishy
stay action
and it was challenging the fascists they
use the same symbols
they create small individual groups with
they say no leaders they have leaders
they do and then they coordinate
for various actions they call them
nationwide so ultimately what you have
are political zealots who believe in the
use of violence for political gain and
terror
uh for political gain what they'll do is
they'll tell you and they'll have allies
in media tell you there's no such thing
as antifa it's not a group
well that's a semantic manipulation
they're playing a game here
if i say antifa came out in portland and
attack people
i'm talking about rose city antifa it's
a legitimate group
they have membership they have
membership drives they put out you know
flyers on the or they put out a website
saying here's how you join
our group they have their own
merchandise that says rose city antifa
on it
so it would be like you know the media
is trying to use
a wordplay to trick you into believing
that these various groups don't exist
because if i said you know i went to
portland and antifa came out then i went
to boston and antifa came out they say
ah see that proves it
because there's no connection between
those two groups but it's
the general idea is they they they hold
that same
ideology wearing all black these similar
tactics they use the same symbols
and they typically agree with each other
on their cause
and their you know their means to the
end so you actually have
a loose knit group of various cells that
coordinate with each other using
violence against their political
opponents
for the most part instigating it
outright to to
to win and it works for them you know
the example i often give to people
why is it that social media is so
willing to censor
right-wing individuals but anti-fuzz
literally organizing
violent riots online even probably right
now they've been doing it
you know all year and for the past
several years and it's simple
antifa in say san francisco in the bay
area
they'll show up to the to the
headquarters of these big tech companies
and they'll trash the place
so these companies say well well you
know leave them alone but there's not
going to be a conservative
group marching to twitter hq with
pitchforks and torches
so long as big companies keep giving
antifa what they want
or showing them their tactics work
they'll keep doing what they do
as for the loosenet nature of what they
do it's all on purpose
the reason why they don't have an
official nationwide organization is very
it's
it's it's actually really easy to
understand when you look at the proud
boys
obviously the proud boys in antifa are
not the same things but there are
similarities in that you have
these these groups that fight on this on
the ground the proud boys have a
chairman
enrique tario well they've banned him
from dozens of banks they've banned them
from all these different platforms
you give someone a leader they use that
to actually try and discredit the rest
of your group
antifa knows this i've actually talked
to people going back to occupy wall
street who have straight up said
no leaders as soon as you put someone up
they'll smear they'll character
assassinate
so it is on purpose they say they don't
have leaders
however law enforcement knows who the
individual cell leaders are i would
imagine
and i think some of them got doxed
recently so it's really it's
it's not you know their tactics aren't
perfect but
i will say the left is much much better
at street level organizing than the
right
and so you end up with a media narrative
that can't understand what antifa is or
outright defends them on purpose
i think there's there's two things
you've got the activist media that hates
donald trump
and they're saying you know oh antifa is
no big deal but they're saying it
because
they want to protect antifa you then
have these local reporters these people
who are probably
you know they have good intentions
they're trying to be objective and fair
but they can't grasp the concept of
antifa as a group
because antifa has specifically
obfuscated what they really are
so you can't report on what they are
then you get someone like say andy no or
elijah schaefer
someone like at one point what i was
doing and we can actually accurately
break it down a report on the ground
they get really angry about that and we
all saw what happened to andy no
you know when he was out there in
portland they physically beat him they
left him bleeding and covered in you
know milkshake and stuff like that
those are the people they're really
worried about but long story short
their their radical far left they
typically are authoritarian communists
but not all of them some of them might
just be
they might be like left anarchist i know
there's a big debate over whether or not
anarchists can actually be left or right
but
they view themselves that way they'll
view themselves as socialists but the
big the big issue i see with antifa
is that you might find someone who will
try and lie and justify no no we don't
believe in violence where it's
self-defense
but these are the narratives they like
to use to get away with what they do and
so long as you have these mainstream
resistance type democrats who hate trump
they won't call these groups out
and that's been something i've
experienced going back to occupy wall
street
where the peaceful legitimate protesters
are told by these groups to respect
their quote diversity
of tactics it's this it's the stupidest
idea i've ever heard the idea that
you're going to engage in some kind of
strategy against a big system but
diversify what that strategy is makes no
sense you want to have a cohesive plan
as to how you're going to make change
happen the the reality is these groups
say respect our diversity of tactics
because
that's code for getting violent and
hurting people and then you get these
good-natured protesters who just want to
you know wave their little signs and
banners and be heard
now standing back as antifa messes with
people knocks them down starts fires
so i will say i think antifa for the
most part is a colloquial term we use to
describe
the far left extremists who use what's
called the black bloc tactic
where you know they wear hoodies they
wear masks i don't know what we'll call
them in the future
we just called them the black block
anarchists you know 10 years ago now
they're antifa
they're still here they're still rioting
apparently the media calling it for joe
biden did nothing to change their minds
and in fact i think
it's only it's only likely to escalate
as if if we do enter a joe biden
administration because
certainly joe biden won't be strong
enough to deal with these groups that
are pressuring him and attacking him and
getting violent
and we already saw this i believe
recently they attacked a dnc
headquarters saying f joe biden
so anyway there you go i think i've
ranted too much on when antifa
is but we can you know follow up i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show sunday special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content